I study whiskers because they're just
the best lots of people when they hear
about whiskers they think immediately of
cat whiskers but actually other animals
have much better whiskers porcupine
whiskers are just the longest whiskers
I've seen the one I've got back in the
lab is about 45 centimeters long the
fastest whisking that I've seen has been
in Harvest mice which reach up to about
25 times per second which is some of the
fastest movements that mammals can make
humans are really quite unusual to not
have whiskers but we do still have these
whisker holes where our whiskers would
have been and also we even have some
remnants of muscles similar to what we
see in in animals with whiskers I like
to look at something that we see every
day and then find out really cool and
interesting things about them
hi coaches